- Oh, hell yeah, I like Filipino food!
- Yeah.
(introduction music)
- I know nothing about Filipino food.
- I'm Filipino, I'm not a great Filipino.
I don't speak Tagalog.
- I remember I was in the
Filipino street food taste test.
Any food that's in the shape of a ball,
probably Filipino.
(light music)
- Their balls.
- I like the color.
- Woah, that is a weird smell.
- These are corn balls.
- I feel like it's a no.
- These are Filipino,
they're also really good.
- Filipine-yes.
- I'm saying Filipine-yes
based on the ball theory.
(bell dings)
- Woo!
- Balls, Balls, Balls!
(light music)
- I was going to say, right off the bat,
I think this is Filipino.
- It looks like a banana
that was stepped on
and scraped off the bottom of a shoe.
- Put some banana ketchup on
this, it might be Filipino.
- If it's not Filipino, it's got to be
somewhere in South America.
(buzzer buzzes)
- Dang it!
- It was your fault.
- I was right?
- You're right.
(light music)
- I don't really want to eat it.
- I want that chicken.
- It looks like Yoda food.
- It's very gingery, or I
might be making that up.
- No, this isn't Filipino.
(bell dings)
- I feel really stupid right now.
- You were so confident, dang it.
(laughing)
(light music)
- This looks like a spring roll.
- That just smells like yard work.
- I'm going to say it is
Filipino because I like it.
- I've liked everything
that's Filipino as well,
so I'm going to change it to Filipino.
(bell dings)
- Awe.
- You instincts.
- Woo!
- I'm killing this game!
(light music)
- It's so red.
- Yeah, this just looks
like a, what's it called?
- A Devil's dick.
- Yeah, there's a lot of peppers.
- Damn, that's good!
- Damn!
- Not Filipino.
- You sure?
- You know what, you made me doubt myself.
- Tandoori chicken, not Filipino.
- It's --
(buzzer buzzes)
- All right. It was good.
I liked something new, I liked that.
(light music)
- What is this?
- This looks like a delicious pastry.
- This looks like how moist
cake looks in a commercial.
- Most of what we've
eaten that is Filipino
it has eggs in it, so I'm gonna
say that this is Filipino.
(bell dings)
- Look out, Dave, I got them all right.
- You got them all right?
- Filipino people must
love me even more now.
- If I had this, I
wouldn't need a boyfriend.
- You don't need a boyfriend anyway.
- I still don't know
what Filipino food is.
- You've got your sweet cheese,
you've got your barbecue.
- Guys, good job in the Philippines.
Bring some more of that over here.
- I'm surprised how many
of them we got right.
- I'm not, I'm great at this, I killed it.
I knew which ones were Filipino.
- You're welcome, Philippines.
- Yeah, they were all good.
What's there to say?
- Filipino food is good.
- Filipino food is great.